Dieses Mal hat alles zu 100 Prozent geklappt.
Nichts ging schief, als die Falcon Heavy um
18:35 Uhr Ortszeit in Florida vom Launch Complex
39A am Kennedy Space Center abhob.
Es war der erste kommerzielle Flug der Falcon
Heavy und er brachte den Satelliten Arabsat-6A
in eine hohe Umlaufbahn für geostationäre
Satelliten in rund 36tausend Kilometer Höhe.
Clixoom Science & Fiction, den Elon Musk Chrobiken
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Sciencevideos
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s
Herzlich willkommen!
Es geht weiter!
SpaceX geht seinen Weg unbeirrbar.
Das ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Mit der Falcon Heavy haben sie aktuell die
größte Rakete der Welt.
Rund 45 Jahre nach dem Flug der bis heute
noch größten Rakete der Menschheit der Saturn
V startet eine neues Monstrum zum ersten Mal
nicht zum test, sondern mit einer kommerziellen
Nutzlast.
Und keine Rakete kann so viel Nutzlast transportieren.
Je nach Orbit kann sie bis zu 63,8 Tonnen
Last in den Weltraum bringen.
Das ist immens.
Bei der Falcon 9 sind es 22,8 Tonnen, also
nur ein Drittel.
Dabei ist die Falcon Heavy eigentlich eine
umgebaute Falcon 9, oder anders gesagt Die
erste Stufe der Falcon Heavy ist eine umgebaute
erste Stufe der Falcon-9.
Wie bei der Falcon 9 sind 9 Merlin 1D Triebwerke
an Board, die jeweils 845 kilonewton Startschub
leisten.
Dazu kommen zwei Booster mit denselben Spezifikationen.
Zusammen leisten sie unglaubliche 22,8 Meganewton.
Durch die hohe Zahl an Triebwerken können
sogar welche ausfallen, so dass die Mission
dann nicht mal gefährdet wäre.
Die zweite Stufe dagegen entspricht einer
etwas verlängerten zweiten Stufe der Falcon
9 mit einem umgebauten Merlin 1 D Triebwerk
mit 617 Kilonewton Schub.
Es kann 353 Sekunden gezündet werden.
Und auch die Fracht ist rekordverdächtig.
Arabsat 6A er idt der fortschrittlichste kommerzielle
Kommunikationssatellit, der jemals von Lockheed
Martin [7] gebaut wurde.
Seien Solarzellen sind 30 Prozent leichter
und 50 Prozent wirkungsvoller als bisher von
Lockheed verbaut.
Der Start erfolgte an einem historischen Ort.
Von der Apollo-Startrampe Launchpad 39A in
Cape Kennedy Von hier aus starteten alle Apolloflüge
inklusive der legendären Apollo 11.
Elon Musks SpaceX hat die Startrampe für
20 Jahre von der NASA geleast.
Von hier aus wird auch der erste bemannte
Flug einer Falcon Rakete mit einer Dragon
Crew Kapsel im Juli abheben.
Beim Start der Falcon Heavy verlief dieses
Mal alles wie am Schnürchen.
Während beim ersten Mal die Landung des Core
nicht gelang landete auch der dieses Mal perfekt,
wobei die Kamera dabei wieder ausfiel und
die Booster lieferten wieder ein absolut beeindruckendes
Bild ab.
Das ist wirklich absolut sagenhaft.
Und damit können alle drei Elemente der der
ersten Stufe der Facon Heavy wiederverwendet
werden und das senkt die Kosten der Starts
massiv.
90 Millionen Dollar kostet ein Start auf diese
Weise.
Die Nasa arbeitet zur Zeit an einem Konkurrenzstartsystem.
Wobei Konkurrenz kann man eigentlich nicht
mehr sagen.
Der Start einer STS-Rakete der NASA, STS steht
für Space Transportation System, rund eine
Milliatde Dollar kosten wird.
Absurd hohe Kosten.
Schon wird über das Scheitern des Projektes
gemutmaßt.
Es bleibt spannend.
Weltraumaufzüge | Der Weg nach oben auf eine
etwas andere Art.
Draufklicken, anschauen und Raumzeit Vlog
der Zukunft abonnieren Bis dann, bleibt dran!